ich habe grundsätzlich eine neun
millimeter dabei gehabt
da hat sich damals die schießerei
ereignet v leute sind für uns in diesem
extrem wichtig ich habe sachen erlebt im
rotlicht möglich es ist natürlich ein
sehr sehr abgeschlossener bereich data
business clubs sowie zimmervermietung
die hells angels immer mehr als bei
anderen mischten damit unwahrscheinlich
viel geld damit gemacht so großes elend
häufig reden wir ja auch über sex und
ausnutzung von osteuropäischen frauen
mit diesem sprengstoff sollte ein
anschlag auf das rotlichtviertel
hindurch ruhig verübt werden hier wollte
man zuschlagen oder die eine seite
produziert hatte also sarah gegenüber
der nächste händels es ging tatsächlich
darum wirklich diesen klub hier in
deutschland zu etablieren dann hat auch
die gegenseite das nicht auf sich sitzen
lassen und zurückgeschlagen
auch ist wirklich so weit gehen dass man
mir tatsächlich keller schickte und das
macht eigentlich deutlich dass das ein
pulverfass rat kann bestätigen dass von
handgranaten bis panzerfäusten über
kalaschnikows alles da was man zu dem
krieg braucht
[Musik]